c'est pas l'interview mensonge he là
c'est non c'est la
vérité pass c'est maintenant une petite
intervieue spéciale si vous le voulez
bien on ne bouge pas pendant le
[Musique]
jingle bien interview moralité est-ce
que vous avez déjà piqué dans le
porte-emonnaie de votre maman quand vous
étiez petit dans le porte-monnaie de ma
maman j'ai sûrement dû prendre de quoi
aller à un carambar oui d'accord 2000
balles
quoi est-ce que vous êtes déjà sorti
avec la copine d'un
copain j'ai beaucoup de copains
ouais un commerçant se trompe à votre
avantage en vous rendant la monnaie vous
lui faites remarquer oui tout de suite
ça ça m'arrive et ça me ça m'arrive
malheureusement souvent je trouve que
les gens compent de plus en plus mal
c'est votre côté fils de commerçant vous
pensez à vos parents non c'est mon côté
honnête j'aime pas qu'on de l'argent qui
ne m'appartient pas c'est pas
l'interview mensonge hein là c'est non
c'est la vérité vous imaginez hein c'est
un jeu de l'esprit vous avez un
appartement vous possédez un appartement
votre locataire peut plus payer le loyer
c'est un type odieux mais vraiment
odieux il a deux enfants insupportables
vous les foutez dehors jamais non je
d'abord je loue pas d'appartement parce
que je voudrais surtout pas me retrouver
dans ce genre de de situation j'aime pas
ça et quand j'étais président de
l'Office départemental d'achalem
c'est-à-dire 30000 logement dans les
hautes scènes croyez-moi avant
d'expulser quelqu'un il fallait vraiment
qu'on puisse pas arriver à d'autres
solutions j'ai toujours fait en sorte
que les gens soient relogés soient aidés
mis des enquêteurs mis des assistantes
social la bépierre ou quoi là non c'est
c'est je l'ai fait par conviction rien
d'autre je l'ai fait je j'ai pas appris
les tambours peut-être que vousêre de
gauche là si vous continuez comme ça
mais je suis pas de droite ah c'est un
scoop là non non je sais pas ce que
c'est la gauche et la droite j'étais
Gauliste la gauche c'est partagé quand
on a beaucoup d'argent c'est partagé
avec les autres c'est pas gueuler de
payer trop d'impôt toute la journée
parce qu'on sait que ça sert à faire les
hôpitaux vous savez aujourd'hui je sais
pas j'ai pas alors ça a dû changer ça a
dû beaucoup changer la gauche partager
Comment vous avez dit partager partager
le pouvoir non en ce momentent on vous
cite à l'ordre du mérite pour un acte
héroïque en fait vous n'avez pas fait
étiez là quand ça s'est produit mais
vous c'est pas vous qui avez sauvé le
mum de se faire écraser est-ce que vous
dites rien vous prenez la médaille non
au contraire je la remets à celui qui
l'a fait moi je le crois moi aussi et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater dearditu
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu